Ever tried working your way through
meteor spinning or as it's sometimes
called two poi one hand? You might have
found that as you're working your way
through such basic tricks as meteor
weaves as well as one-handed
butterflies, you kind of have a
difficult time keeping the plane
straight between the two different sides
of your hand. So, how can you improve at
this? Well, I've got you covered,
friend.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I'm sharing
with you my five favorite exercises for
getting down plane control in meteor
spinning or two one hand. But before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroera Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all of these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video. So,
first order of business to get out of
the way because everybody asks it and
namely that is what kind of grip am I
using here? The grip that I'm using is
that I'm putting my thumb in poi between
my thumb and my index finger and holding
it in what's commonly known as the key
grip, pinching it between my thumb as
well as the first joint of my index
finger. The other end, my pinky end is
being held between my pinky and ring
fingers and then pressed tightly against
my palm. This is a position where I find
I get maximum control for both ends. And
of course, it presents the oldest
conundrum in Meteor or two po one hand
spinning, which is how do you control
two planes at the same time with just
one hand? Especially when you've got a
fist bundled up so tight keeping those
poi together. So glad you asked. Let's
dive in. Exercise one, swapping
directions.
So your first challenge, should you
choose to accept it, is going to be
getting your thumb end moving while
keeping the pinky end moving as little
as possible. Oh, yeah. And also changing
the direction of your thumb end just in
case you needed a little bit extra
there. How exactly do you do that? I'm
so glad you asked. We're going to go
ahead and start off with our hand
sitting out in front of us like so. And
I want you to hook your index finger
underneath the tether of your thumb and
poi. This is going to give you just a
little bit of extra control over it. And
you'll note it gives you a little bit of
spacing between the two poi. Now, from
here, I'm going to use that uh index
finger to kind of pull the thumb and po
around. I'm going to be spinning it
going counterclockwise to start with
relative to me. And you may find that as
you're spinning the poi around, you wind
up moving the pinky end poi just a
little bit. That's okay. What you do
when that happens is you have your hand
kind of intercept the pinky end poi. So,
if it starts swinging back and forth in
a pendulum, you move your hand in the
same direction as the pendulum to bring
the PO to a stop. So, we're going to go
ahead and get our thumb end moving
around counterclockwise. And I want you
to get in 10 reps spinning the PO
counterclockwise
before bringing it to a stop. Then
you're going to go the opposite
direction. Bring it around clockwise
again. Give me 10 reps before you bring
it down to a stop. And then we're going
to work on going back and forth between
the two. So there's an interesting
little secret hidden inside of this
move. When I get the thumb end poi
moving, namely, as I spin that thumb end
around, I'm angling the plane in such a
way that rather than being straight out
in front of me, it tilts slightly back.
Namely, the top of it is coming towards
my nose and the bottom end of it is
going away from me. This keeps it clear
of the pinky and poi and make sure that
the two of them will not tangle with
each other. This is also a clue as to
how I can do a direction change. Namely,
I can tilt the plane of the poi from the
vertical that's flat in front of me to
being slightly off to one side if I'm
going to do a pendulum off to my right.
When I do that, I have clearance to
bring the thumb end poi back towards me
and avoid the pinky end poi. When I do
the pendulum off to my left, likewise,
I'm angling the plane just slightly, and
that gives me clearance to bring it back
without hitting the pinky end. So, from
the front, I can go from
counterclockwise to clockwise. And I can
go from clockwise to counterclockwise
when I angle the plane in this manner.
You can also see it from the side here.
I start off going counterclockwise. I do
my pendulum. I bring it back and that
gets me going clockwise. I do my
pendulum the other way and what do you
know? I'm back to counterclockwise. So
work on doing these direction changes
going back and forth between your
counterclockwise and your clockwise. And
try and keep the pinky and po as still
as possible as you go back and forth
between these two directions. Yes, this
is where we're starting and not where
we're ending with this because as it
turns out, there's a lot of training
that we can do to be able to
independently control the two sides of
our hands. And the next one on that list
is
drill number two, horizontal control.
So, way back in the day, I was shown
this drill as an example of something
that meteor spinning phenom Andy House
had created as a way to get himself
really, really, really dialed in with
each end of his meteor spinning. So,
remember how in the last drill we got
just the thumb end spinning? Well, we're
going to apply some of that knowledge,
but rather than spinning it in a
vertical plane, we're instead going to
spin it in a horizontal plane above our
heads. I am doing this with the PO
spinning counterclockwise as I look up
from down below at it. Now, here comes
the fun part. Cuz as I spin my thumb end
around counterclockwise, I'm now going
to switch to my pinky end spinning
around counterclockwise. And as I do
that, I'm going to immobilize my thumb
end. So, just my pinky end spinning
right now, not my thumb. And then I'm
going to switch back the other way,
keeping my pinky end as isolated and
mobile as possible. And my thumb end
going around counterclockwise. So, thumb
end spins and then pinky end spins. and
then thumb end spins and then pinky end
spins. When I switch to pinky, I am
trying as much as possible to keep most
of my hand riveted in place and only
move around those fingers that are most
directly interacting with the pinky end
po here. So again, your goal here is to
get in 10 reps with the thumb end
spinning and 10 reps with the pinky end
spinning and immobilize the other end as
you do that. And of course, get the end
that was formerly spinning to completely
stop when you switch. No small challenge
there, right? And yes, by now your
forearm should absolutely be burning
with all of the different muscles that
you are activating and strengthening.
And that's only going to get worse from
here. Exercise number three, vertical
switch.
So given that the first exercise
involved us spinning the poi in vertical
planes and the second exercise involved
us swapping which end of our hand we
were spinning in a horizontal plane. You
may have surmised that we are about to
put the two pieces together. All right.
So this is going to wind up starting a
lot like our first exercise did. Namely,
I'm going to stick my hand out in front
of me with the two PO kind of aligned
straight away. And under the thumb end
poi, I'm going to kind of hook my index
finger to give myself just a little bit
of clearance and leverage. From here,
I'm going to get that thumb end poi
spinning around counterclockwise. Now,
here's where things get interesting, cuz
what I'm basically going to do is I'm
going to imagine that I'm going to do a
big exaggerated stall with that thumb
end, taking it up and over. And I'm
going to twist my wrist around so that
now my thumb is pointed down and my the
my pinky end is pointing up. And I'm
going to keep my pinky and po spinning
as my thumb end poi is now immobilized.
Again, the thumb end po is probably
going to have just a little bit of
momentum on it, but you're going to want
to move your hand around to the point
where you can get it to stop moving and
keep that pinky end spinning while the
thumb end just sits there. So, part of
what's making this work is that I am
switching from a place where my thumb
end is slightly further away from me to
a place where it's now my pinky end that
is slightly further away from me. I have
changed the orientation of my wrist from
being like this where I'm kind of
pointing my thumb out away from me to
like this where I'm kind of pointing my
pinky out away from me. This is kind of
an uncomfortable place to stick your
arm, but as you train yourself to do it,
it will get more and more familiar. All
right, so now we got to go back and
forth between the two ends. I'm going to
start off by having my thumb end
spinning around. And I'm going to do
that big elaborate stall to get my pinky
end now spinning in the vertical plane.
From here, I want to swap back to having
my thumb come up top. And that's going
to switch me back to having the thumb
end spinning and my pinky end just kind
of sitting there inert. Let's do it
again. The thumb end goes over in that
stall. We immobilize it as the pinky end
spins. And then we swap which one is on
top and which one's in front to get the
thumb end spinning and the pinky end
inert. Go back and forth like that. No
fewer than 10 times. Goodness. And don't
worry, that is the last exercise that
I'm going to have you do where we're
going to swap back and forth between
thumb and pinky ends because I think I
have tortured you enough there. But that
doesn't mean that our work is over.
Exercise number four, flattening
butterflies.
So, not only is this the first exercise
we've had on this list that explicitly
involves the PO spinning in opposite
directions or butterfly, I'm pretty sure
it is also the first exercise on this
list that I created myself. See, when
you spin a one-handed butterfly here,
you have to work in such a way that the
two po can spin in opposite directions
and not run into each other. And just as
is the case when we do this with a
butterfly performed with both hands, the
way to do it is to have the two poi
planes at an angle. So they look like an
X from the side. The trick is when we
first start off spinning our poi and
butterfly, we're not very good at doing
this. And in most cases, our poi are
going to run into each other as we try
to spin them around. So how do we get
down this ability to change the pitch of
the PO planes? Well, when we start up
doing this one-handed butterfly, we're
actually going to exaggerate this angle
right here. We're going to try and get
the PO planes as close to horizontal as
possible. And when we do that,
fascinatingly, it actually almost looks
as though the PO are spinning split time
same direction. And then we bring them
back to vertical so that they are very
cleanly and together opposites. We want
to make the planes as close to vertical
as we possibly can get them. And then we
want to flatten them back down to a
horizontal again. We want to go back and
forth between these two extremes. Going
up to vertical and down to horizontal.
So the goal here is to be able to do 10
reps going back and forth between those
vertical planes and those horizontal
planes and back again. That is the work.
And oh my goodness, is it going to make
your one-handed butterflies so much
better. And hey, if you can't get enough
one-handed butterfly exercises, I have a
special bonus exercise attached to the
version of this video that is available
only to my Patreon subscribers, I will
go ahead and leave a link to that video
down in the description, so you can go
check it out for yourself. So, before I
share with you my final exercise for
getting down your meteor and 2.1 hand
spinning, I do have a quick favor to
ask. If you've come this far, I'm sure
that it means that you are quite into PO
spinning and you are interested in
seeing more videos on that topic. And
the good news is I make tons of those
videos. If you want to see them, the way
you do that is you hit the subscribe
button as well as ring the bell. That
makes sure that you get notified the
next time I drop a video so you get
first draft in line to go check it out.
Plus, which it helps out the channel so
everybody wins. Thank you in advance.
And now my final pick for exercises that
help you develop meteor and 2.1 hand
spinning. Exercise number five,
one-handed transitions. So, so far
everything on this list has really been
about getting down specific plane
control with each side of your hand. And
that's all fine and dandy, but when it
comes down to really getting down your
meteor or 2.1 hand spinning, you also
need to get transitions down as well.
And the bear of it is there's really no
way to cleanly do stalls with 2.1 hand
and not have one end influence the
other. Unfortunately, the geometry of
stalls is such that if you perform
stalls with one hand, you're probably
performing stalls with the other one
with some limited exceptions. So, what
options does that leave us with?
Personally, my favorite transition
option for 2.1 hand is pendulums. I
personally think that pendulums are
criminally underrated. So, if I'm
starting from a place where I am using
that one-handed butterfly, what I can do
is I can start to take away momentum
from my pinky end. And when that
happens, I can carry the thumb end
around into a reverse fourbeat thumbled
meteor weave like so. And the reverse is
also true. I can drop the pinky end into
another pendulum and switch its
direction as the thumb end comes around.
So, we want to think that as the pinky
end comes up, we're trying to kill the
momentum on it and we're swapping the
thumb end around underneath it to get
into this weave. Likewise, when we come
back out of this, we are trying to get
the pinky end to do a pendulum off to
our right and drop back down as the
thumb end is coming around to get us
into that one-handed butterfly. So,
one-handed butterfly, two meteor weave,
and then back to one-handed butterfly
like so. So, part of the work on this
exercise is of course performing a
pendulum with only one hand at a time.
And part of the work of it is also
finding the timing here. Making sure
that we are keeping both poi moving in
such a way that we can find the timing
and direction that we're looking for
when we come out of the transition. But
I also think that this exercise is a
good one for getting you started with
these transitions and making it feel
more natural to perform the pendulums
with just one end of this assembly every
single time. Cool. So, those were my
picks for five exercises that will
improve your meteor/2.1
hand spinning. Do you have exercises
that you prefer for getting these things
down? Leave me a comment and let me
know.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a huge
shout out to my FL patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you
all so much for your very, very generous
support. And if you out there watching
would like to get your name in the
credits or access to a host of other
awesome rewards, you can do that by
signing up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll leave a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards
to go sign up for that. Please, please,
please help me out in my mission of
bringing po spinning and flow arts to
the whole wide world. Thank you in
advance. And if you'd like to learn more
about meteor or twopoint one hand or
even three-po spinning in general, I
have an entire playlist of videos I've
done on those topics over the years that
I'll go ahead and link to up on screen
here. That awesome playlist right there.
I'll also include a link down in the
description. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.